covet 19 is causing an increasing number
of deaths in africa with health
authorities unable to contain its spread
the world health organization says the
delta variant of the virus is to blame
particularly in south africa which has
lost 67
000 people that's 40 percent of all
pandemic deaths on the continent
the sheer numbers are putting south
africa's health care system under severe
stress
as dw's christine mundo reports from
johannesburg
the graves are still fresh people laid
to rest here
have not been gone long the third wave
of covet 19 in south africa
has been the grim reaper the country was
not
ready for
all of the graves here and there are
hundreds
of them were dug in the last few weeks
really in the months of june
and july most of the people buried here
are victims of covet 19. the managers of
this burial estate say they've been
conducting up to 10
funerals a day
at this dialysis clinic in the western
part of johannesburg
the beds in this ward are unusually
empty
this is a busy center we closed around
seven to eight
but of late we are now closing at two
because a lot of people
really did succumb to the virus
unfortunately because our patients
are you know immunocompromised we lost
quite a lot of them
when you look around you realize wow so
many people are gone
south africa's healthcare system has
been overwhelmed as the delta variant
first detected in india has dominated
new infections here
many sick people have been turned away
from hospitals
a lot of hospitals were struggling so we
ended up getting called as a dialysis
center which is
not actually supposed to deal with
covered people getting calls from people
all over
johannesburg asking us to assist with
oxygen
including our own patients so we tried
to assess those that we could
but we literally couldn't assist anybody
i mean everybody so what we did then is
that we're giving oxygen to those who
are literally gasping
for air frontline healthcare workers
have not been spared dr neledi guam
works at a public psychiatry hospital
she's just recovered from covert 19 but
some of her peers
have not been as lucky a lot of health
care workers have passed on
a lot a lot have needed long term
hospitalizations you know i'm a
self-contracted covert at some point
luckily mine was not so severe you know
i was able to take up my symptoms at
home
but not everyone is as lucky the third
wave came and it was a proper wave
it was just like a tsunami wave the
third wave has been south africa's
darkest hour yet
in the coronavirus pandemic it's forced
the government to close schools
ban all public gatherings and prohibit
the sale of alcohol
and in a country with so much poverty
already the measures
are having a devastating economic impact